when you hear the word chivalry today
two things probably pop into your head
a man being chivalrous to a woman
holding the door open for her paying for
her dinner or perhaps even placing his
coat over a puddle as to make sure she
doesn't get her feet wet the second
thing you might think of is a knight in
shining armor fighting a dragon and
saving a damsel in distress
chivalry in the medieval era was quite a
bit different to these modern
conceptions
it was a code of ethics which included
rules and expectations that knights at
all times behaved in a certain manner
[Music]
before we get into the meat and potatoes
of chivalry let's go over some history
chivalry started in france in the 12th
century
originally the word referred to being
like a knight a knight was chivalrous in
the same way that an artist is artistic
it was an immutable characteristic
by the way if you're curious about the
life of a knight in the medieval era
watch my older video here
but starting in the mid 12th century the
word started to mean the ideal
characteristics of a knight
a knight was no longer chivalrous
because of his horse and his lance
instead he was expected to present a
certain set of virtues like honor
honesty and generosity
you see knights really didn't have a
good reputation before the introduction
of the shavarik code they were basically
hired thugs who while highly trained and
heavily armed had a penchant for
violence and destruction
we don't know exactly why the conception
of chivalry changed to include an
ethical code
but it was probably at least in part due
to the influence of the church
the clergy of the time insisted that a
true knight was one who not only fought
for and was loyal to their lord but was
a good christian and a defender of the
church as well
this idea especially caught on due to
the crusades
in the 14th century a new literary genre
was established the romance
medieval romances were poems and songs
that took inspiration from folklore and
history to tell stories of adventure
forbidden romance and knights in shining
armor think for example of the stories
of king arthur and the knights of the
round table
these stories were extremely influential
on knights of the time who began to want
to emulate the characters from the
stories
while it is common to talk of a
chevalric code as though there was an
agreed-upon list of rules all nights
followed no such code existed
if you look at a knight's armor you
won't see a pouch to hold a rulebook or
pamphlet on proper chevalric behavior
chivalry was an informal thing but it
was taken very seriously by most knights
common qualities seen as chivalrous that
appeared more often than not were
courage
military prowess honesty
honor loyalty
justice good manners and generosity
with the privilege of our modern
viewpoint we can break the rules of
chivalry down into three main sections
warrior chivalry
religious chivalry and courtly love
a knight's first duty was to their lord
he was to fight in the military
campaigns of said lord
and do so effectively knights who showed
cowardice by fleeing a battle were often
stripped of their knighthood altogether
in jon fuisar's chronicles in which the
hundred years war is covered in great
detail fusar described a battle in which
a group of french knights repeatedly
charged a castle defended by english
longbowmen this tactic repeatedly failed
and many knights died
fusar asserted that the french knew this
tactic might fail but it was seen as a
more chivalrous approach than more
subtle tactics
knights were also expected to be good
christians and to defend the church many
of the rituals of knighthood like the
accolade where squire was knighted by
their monarch
involved many religious elements
the soon-to-be night was meant to have a
night of prayer before the ceremony for
instance
this religious element played a large
part in the crusades in which the pope
in rome requested that warriors across
europe go to retake the holy land from
the muslims and thousands of knights
joined the cause
going on such a crusade was seen as one
of the most chivalrous things a night
could do knights were also meant to act
a certain way outside the battlefield
they were called to be honest and
generous especially to those less
fortunate
they were meant to be well-mannered
understanding the etiquette and rituals
of court bowing to the right people
addressing royalty correctly eating with
the right tableware that sort of thing
one of the most famous parts of chivalry
was a night's treatment of women
[Music]
in the modern day the term chivalry
usually refers to a respectful and
gentlemanly treatment of women this was
indeed a part of chivalry in the middle
ages too though perhaps not quite in the
way we might think
courtly love described a specific type
of platonic or at the very least
non-sexual love between a knight and a
lady who was usually unavailable either
by being already married or being of a
higher social class
think lancelot and gwynevere from the
arthurian legends guinevere was already
married to king arthur but lancelot fell
deeply in love with her at first it was
just pining and lancelot had no plans to
act on his feelings but once gwenevere
returned his affections they started a
sordid love affair
of course in the ideal courtly love
relationship no affair would take place
it was seen to be beneficial for a young
knight to have a lady to have his eye on
it would civilize him and make him an
even more effective knight as he would
try to impress her
ladies would sometimes give knight's
objects like a hankerchief as a show of
favor before the knight went off to
battle
this was meant to encourage the knight
to fight his best
as you can see this sort of culture
really only apply to high class women
also there's less respect and more
admiration the knights put these women
on a pedestal
one that was impossible to live up to
and i think that leads well into our
next section
[Music]
so far we've only been discussing the
ideals of chivalry
but as i mentioned chivalry was an
informal thing because of this vagueness
chivalry was not always followed in the
way we might expect
and sometimes it simply wasn't followed
at all
the truth is historians have a difficult
time separating which parts of chivalry
were really followed and which were just
fiction
you see much of what we know of chivalry
comes from those romances from the 14th
century
how much of this was descriptive of the
real chevalric code isn't easy to know
there are numerous examples of knights
not acting in chivalrous ways
for instance during the fourth crusade a
large band of knights decided to sack
constantinople one of the largest
christian cities in the world at the
time this decision indirectly resulted
in the ottoman takeover of the city a
few hundred years later
this instance is just one of many that
seem counter-intuitive to our
perceptions of chivalry and whether this
and other instances are examples of
knights falling short of their
self-imposed ideals or if many of the
ideals were never taken seriously in the
first place is difficult to ascertain
also chivalry had more than one function
in society while it was a way of keeping
brutish knights in line it also had the
secondary function of solidifying the
separation between the upper classes
and the lower classes
only well-born men were able to become
knights
and therefore only upperclassmen were
taught chevalric ideals this disparity
continues to this day where manners and
etiquette are seen as upper class things
some contemporary historians have a
habit of seeing chivalry as either a
poetic and literary invention that was
never really followed by medieval
knights or as a chauvinistic elitist
system that's only purpose was to
solidify the power of the nobility both
of these charges have some merit of
course but i think they go too far
many nights in the middle ages took the
chevalret code very seriously and while
they might not always have lived up to
it it doesn't mean it wasn't real to
them
also while chivalry was not perfect it
did have some positives
for one chivalry really did bring
knights in line before the 12th century
knights were feared by basically
everybody monks in their monasteries and
churches would often pray that the
knights wouldn't raid their homes
so while nights after the introduction
of chivalry weren't perfect they were
certainly worse before
so that's chivalry a complicated
misunderstood ethical code followed by
men who had enough money to buy armor a
sword and a horse
hopefully you enjoyed the video and if
you did please leave the video a like
subscribe to the channel leave a comment
share the video all that good stuff bye
[Music]